foreign
if we're all ready I think it's nine
o'clock so we can start our first
uh interim study bill which is uh HB
1137 relative to the duty of school
boards to provide education
this was voted interim study I think by
a 12 to 6 margin
um and uh just
for clarification of the members of this
subcommittee I had as cordelli Hobson
Moffett Mullen
Tanner
and Hall
is that
sound proof
yeah right you just wouldn't be able to
vote on if we have votes you know right
um
and then the second one we have a 10 30
is
um
1664 and I have as the members of that
subcommittee cordelli Hobson
Tanner and Porter
so
um so the first order I guess is 11 37
and I was just gonna
throw it open first to any committee
members who had General comments
um about the bill and then we could go
through
um there are a number of different
sections and Provisions this we could go
through them
um one by one just to get a feel for uh
the committee's
feeling on whether any of these sections
should proceed
um or not
and
um
representative yeah you've got the um
and uh there's a sign in sheet and a
copy of the bill there as well if you
need that
yeah great does uh yeah representative
Mullen thank you representative cordelli
um I'm just curious uh with regards to
this bill I know that you're the prime
sponsor on the Bell so you are the app
to person to answer this
um
there are a lot of changes to 189 one
made in this bill and I'm just wondering
if there was an opportunity for the
school boards Association or
the school administrators Association
did anybody collaborate with you on the
language of this bill
uh no
thank you
other General comments
I'm president of Lakers
it's one thing I'd love to see added on
here and that is that the res have it
actually in here in place that says the
responsibility of the school board if
the town the people of the Town petition
appropriately to have a special meeting
that they must have it
as opposed to what a number of towns
including mine did and then after we did
the petition with all the right
signatures and everything and in spite
of the fact that the law says shall
they ignored it and voted to not hold
the meeting that we petitioned to have
held so and there were a number of quite
a few others in uh the state that did
the same thing and so put it here
so that it's all laid out for them so
they can't say well
our lawyers said
um yeah I think that is a separate
statute and I think you're correct in
that it says shall
um but I I agree that a number of
districts did not
agree to adhere to the Shell I'm not
sure if it uh fits in here or it could
be strengthened the in the existing
statute but it's something to take a
look at for next year I I just figured
that since it was all yeah since we were
putting all these things all in one
place
so that they can see them because they
made excuses about it not being their
Duty well if it's in here it's their
Duty
representative Tanner
thank you sorry I was late this morning
now fog
um I have a couple of questions one is
to representative lakis if I could uh
what did the lawyer say was the reason
that they could circumvent the
the law they basically said oh well then
there's this other provision that we if
they don't do it we can take them to
court and so basically they were relying
on the fact that it costs money to take
them to court and that we wouldn't do it
so they were just flat out ignoring the
law
assuming that nobody would take them to
court
so what would prevent them from doing
the same thing now and forcing you to go
to court on it
well
nothing I had wanted another part as
well that had some penalties
my second question is is actually more
of a request and that is when I went
through the the laws in the book that
are kind of scattered around
some of this duplicates what's already
in
some of the new
verbiage actually duplicates what's in
here I was wondering if there was a
possibility to have a side by side of
what is currently in law
um from maybe our our secretary of a
side by side of what's currently in law
and what is being proposed with this new
language because it seems like
some of it's conflicting some of it's
the same I mean I like I said I was
going through it
um the last couple days and and uh just
it it doesn't seem to be
coordinated and and if you want an
effort I think it should be coordinated
with the with the current statutes
um we could see about that maybe we
first will have the discussion
um and see if
um the subcommittee thinks any provision
should proceed with a recommendation of
legislation for next year
um and then take it from there
um
uh but uh since uh the school boards
Association was mentioned I was
wondering if they would like to come up
and offer any general comments
thank you chairman cordelli uh good
morning members of the committee bear
Christina from the school boards
Association
um I think I was on the stand
um and put it that way for about an hour
when this bill was heard last year so I
really don't have anything new to add to
that um I'm just here to sort of listen
to the conversation if there are
specific questions I'm happy to answer
those but I really don't have any
specific comment relative to the the
bill that was interim studied
um my notes um indicated that uh please
correct me if I'm wrong but uh your
general position was uh no position on
on the bill is that accurate correct uh
thank you Mr chair yes we did not take a
position on this bill last year when I
initially testified okay
thank you thank you
um and uh I'm sure there might be
questions as we proceed through the list
of uh recommendations and I'll be I'll
be here for the morning so thank you
great
okay
um
shall we start down
the list of some of the uh
responsibilities for the school board
that were in the bill
if everyone has a copy
um
it starts on my
copy as line 16 on the first page with
the school board shall be responsible
for
if if anyone is it maybe do you have
different line numbers I I do I have uh
section two starting on line nine okay
um maybe I'll get a copy of to match
yours
um
so uh do you have any uh comments on
that section I do thank you for asking
representative cordelli
um first of all I would like to know
um
in Roman 2 the sort of the introductory
paragraph the language has been changed
from establishing structure
accountability advocacy or whatever to
approving and overseeing and I'm
wondering why that language uh what the
deliberation was over the language
change and also in that same paragraph
content was added to the list and I'm
wondering as representative Tanner
referenced um
whether or not
content uh
under the responsibilities of of
approving and overseeing as far as the
school board is concerned Why that was
added to that section
uh thank you
um
I thought that
um well
approving an overseeing versus
establishing first
establishing means to put in place
basically to establish
these things but I think that school
board responsibilities go beyond just
establishing but they have to
manage and oversee as time progresses as
well so that I wanted to be at a future
look ahead that it's not just putting
something in place and then moving on
so that's why I added especially the
over scene
can I ask just a follow-up to that is
there any provision anywhere in the law
or in any of this legislation for
training school board members on
approving overseeing and whatnot of the
responsibilities listed
um I I think in the school boards
Association can correct me if wrong if
I'm wrong but I believe we had testimony
from them several times last year about
the training that the School Board
Association offers to new board members
yeah I'm specifically referencing the
addition of content I'm just wondering
um what the standard will be for school
board members to
uh approve
and oversee content in areas that they
may not have expertise and I certainly
wouldn't want to be
in charge of the chemistry content well
I think school boards should be
approving uh curriculum
um whether it be a chemistry or history
um
so you know that's the reason for the
addition of content
representative Tanner I bet you you're
glad I'm here
um could you explain to me then the
difference between content and
curriculum
foreign
I think maybe content
um
goes beyond just curriculum but policies
and so forth
um
but uh you know I you know uh I
certainly uh see your point
um and it could be uh related to uh just
curriculum
just just as a follow-up on that
um so this the state is kind of
responsible for setting the standards
and the school board's responsible for
setting that curriculum and then the
teacher actually
um does the content work and that
content can be you know and is reviewed
on a on a basis uh with the with the um
building principle and and that sort of
thing but that's been my experience uh
as far as the structure of schools and
how things are kind of handled down uh
and as representative Mullen said you
know I'd I'd be hard-pressed even as a
trained educator and a person that's got
a lot of content in my head uh to
approve content for physics or chemistry
or or even
um the field of Health with the way
things are changing so rapidly so
um I would say that that uh I would take
the content out of that that particular
line
thank you any further
um discussion on that
area
um see not happen if we go to uh uh
responsibility for curriculum
instructional programs textbooks
uh Etc below that in lines
foreign
16 down
um
any feelings about uh
having those included as a board
responsibility
or the necessity for inclusion of them
can I just ask a clarifying question
representative cordelli sure so when
when you look at curriculum or textbooks
or educational materials or whatever and
we're looking at board approval
um
is there a uniform process by which a
board would Grant approval
or is there an option for them to say to
the superintendent of schools or the
curriculum and instruction people or
whatever just make a recommendation and
then we will approve it I want our
school board members going to be
required to read these textbooks in
order to give approval
thank you
um my personal thinking is that uh
textbooks should be reviewed by board
members
um for uh approval
um a vote of the board to approve a new
textbook I remember an instance
um when I was on school board back in
Connecticut
and we had a new history Social Studies
textbook and
um in the chapter on the Cold War
uh did not mention
um President Reagan or the pope it was
all about Gorbachev which I thought was
a misstatement of history and I remember
in other instance looking at uh
curriculum
for early
uh 20th century America
um history class and as a film to
illustrate what the early 20th century
was like in America they wanted to show
the movie The Godfather
which I objected to and that was removed
but I think that uh
I I think that school board members
should review textbooks
before the board approves in yeah I'm
just trying to figure out how somebody
in a K-12 system
is going to
as a as a school board member is going
to have the
wherewithal or the availability of time
to read all of the text all of the new
textbooks I would assume that this would
mean that
that would have to be a review of
textbooks that are currently being used
as well
that was not my intent
I'm not sure if it's
yeah it just says textbooks approvals
right but whether or not that means
approving the ones that are there now or
I would not take it as such but that's
my interpretation of
yes
so my experience on the other end of the
spectrum being a teacher
um is that when things came to the to
the school board oftentimes they went to
the table of contents or they went to
the index looking for
specific words or phrases that were kind
of catchphrases in the current whatever
the current whether it was the Cold War
era or you know whatever they their
particular
um
I guess I their their particular
ideology or whatever
um they were there for
um presented
um and at that time uh things would come
to the school board the school board
would point it out that it was there and
then uh the text textbook or the teacher
who was using that textbook would come
in and and talk about how it was
presented and whether it was a balanced
present presentation or not
um
so I I think that um you know textbook
approval uh
is is problematic uh you know again
um I'm not sure that
even as a trained educator I would be
feel confident in making a decision
about
textbooks and content area particularly
at the at the high school level that I
knew little or nothing about really
um
so I
I think that's
that's a little bit vague and needs to
be looked in thank you
thank you
representative
chair uh very interesting bill to me is
a former teacher and a former elected
board member
um as the representative mullen's
comment which I found very interesting
um about reading every book I would
probably want to point out that as
legislators I'm not sure that all of us
read every single bill before we vote on
on the bills and what we do here is we
defer to subject experts in other words
committee recommendations that type of
thing so uh but when there's a
particular area or or item of particular
interest you know that's where we would
drill down I think and and certainly
have to read you know I wouldn't
necessarily read every chemistry book I
would just trust that the the science
department right but representative
cordelli's point about the cohort
something like that that would come up I
think every everyone buddy on the board
should look at the at that piece of it
that is you know potentially
controversial but I think deferring to
subject experts whether it's in the
legislature or in the school Community
you think we have to we have to do that
thank you representative Moffett that
was exactly my point you know don't we
have people in positions with content
knowledge that uh can make
recommendations or not and wouldn't we
um representative cordelli would what
representative moffatt is referring to
uh I I think school boards have that
experience I think parents come forward
with controversial information in their
in their estimation and ask for a review
um
I'm not sure how this would
alleviate that situation because I think
that
you know you put five people in the room
and put a problem in front of them they
see five different things right so uh I
just don't know to what end that would
serve
thank you
um
so
um anything else in relation to ABC or D
that anyone wants to
mention
otherwise yes representative and Mr
chair um can you just follow up on your
cold war book I'm just curious did that
that get tossed what happened to it uh
you said Godfather didn't write um board
voted to uh accept the textbook anyway
and we are the only one that was against
it or was it a majority vote right I
mean yeah she was a majority vote yeah
okay thank you
foreign
like to
um
Express their opinion via a vote on some
of these individual line item items such
as textbooks and as to whether they
should be brought forward as future
legislation
no okay
would anyone like to
proceed in that manner
right or would you like to vote as a
subcommittee just on the uh the bill
itself
am I correct that I mean that's the task
today is a is a up or down right but but
we I think it's uh within our purview to
say that we think that uh sections could
be brought forward as future legislation
okay I I mean I don't mind having that
discussion but I'd like to go through
the bill first okay is that agreeable
with everybody then
may I ask a question thank you cordelli
um so
I don't I guess I don't know how to
phrase this but I'm kind of wondering
um
the school board is the first line of
defense for parents if parents are
questioning materials they go to the
school board is is that
correct no if they're questioning
materials what is what is the opinion of
where you go first
I thought representative Hall I was
going to say the teacher
you know if there's something going on
something material in my class then I
would think that that parent would come
to me first
and then it could get to the school
board
after the principal
representative
um I taught sex education so you can
imagine that
my job and noting that it was a very
sensitive subject and and noting that we
needed a lot of Parental involvement
with that we actually proactively
um had sessions where people came in uh
were able to see the films we were
showing in class were able to actually
see the content of the of the course
because we had no textbook because
things changed so rapidly at that time
if any parent wished to
um you know we had obviously that was
kind of like a focus group it was open
you know to to anybody that would like
to come
um but if a parent then objected to any
particular part of that they're allowed
to substitute what they feel uh they
want to do or uh alternative curriculum
alternative texts that sort of thing so
that's that's usually the first line of
defense I think in the unfortunately I
don't know if it was covid or whatever
but I I think unfortunately in this
uh climate right now a lot of people
jump the gun and they just they go to
the public or they go to the school
board and scream and yell and
um you know protest what what they they
think uh there
um it's much more
um
it's much more
uh gentle on the student uh who becomes
this the kind of the Pawn in the whole
deal it's much more gentle on them and
gentle in the whole situation if it's
done uh with the teacher and at the
local level and and uh you know
arrangements are made
I agree with you
um rep Tanner that um that's probably
the best way to go first
um but a teacher being transparent is a
is a
um important piece of that so I
appreciate what you uh what you added
thanks
representative Lucas
I kind of think of the school board as
as not the first line of defense but not
quite the last line of defense before
you get to the doe but last line of
local defense but they're the ones who
should be responsible and that's the
then that's the part of this is they're
the ones that should be responsible or
are responsible ultimately for what's
taught in the schools and so
they need to approve I think the
textbooks now
whether they do it by saying okay
who knows about this what do you think
of this textbook I mean I certainly
would go to more than just the science
teacher who is recommending the textbook
there's plenty of resources out there to
to check out the textbook and say what
do you guys think of this I mean you can
go online and and
even in here a lot of different things
but ultimately they're the one that's
responsible for the school for what's
taught in the school for all of that and
how can they do that if they haven't
even looked at what's being taught
sure so I think the the comment between
representative Moffett and
representative Mullen before
um have you know schools are are
um have a hierarchy just like you said
that you know the teacher's the first
and and teachers try to be transparent
and obviously the longer you teach the
better you get at being transparent
um but the the hierarchy is the teacher
then you that and then within that
particular school you have a a building
principal who also should be involved in
you know I always went to the building
principle if I thought I had a film that
wasn't going to might drum up some
controversy uh then the the principal
actually goes to the superintendent and
at the superintendent's level is the
specialist usually on the curriculum
um you know they're the ones they're
hired by the school board to actually
Implement and oversee all this
all these things that you're now shoving
to the school board the school board is
a is is they're not educational experts
for the most part they're not they're
not paid exceptionally well they're
they're like Volunteers in the community
they're that are running for office that
all of us are running for office now
know how fragile that is and
um you know to start putting all this on
them
um
as they have to micromanage curriculum
textbooks blah blah blah they if if the
superintendent is doing their job if the
principals are doing their job if the
teacher's doing their job then you know
it would be like like Ian musk going in
and talking about you know the various
parts of the rockets that are going to
send the the people up you know the
micromanaging the seals and all that
stuff I mean it's in a in a hierarchy
um I think you're just throwing a lot up
to the top that should be
coming through
thank you version of Hobson
sorry to belabor this but so as a school
board member I felt like parents would
come to me and say did you know about
this do you know about that
um
most often times I didn't or I didn't
have enough knowledge I couldn't explain
it
um and as a parent I got onto the school
board because I wanted to have a more
investment into what my kids were
learning I wanted to understand it I
wanted to help so I guess at this point
I don't know what
what is the school board responsible for
what are we being held responsible for
in the community and I look at it like a
go-between between the parents kind of
like what a representative is you know
it's my job to explain things that are
happening in the school I'm a
representative of the community
at the school level so
um that brings up some confusion for me
um
with with um you know your position or
the other side I guess if you could help
me explain would the school boards
Association like to weigh in
thank you again uh chairman cordelli
um
trying to make it where I I want to
start with this um you know and
representative Hopson um you know pretty
the last couple of years and some of the
same concerns and issues proper School
Board role
um I I tend to tell people to start with
the Department of Education rules
ed30303.01
is the um is the rule for uh I'm sorry
303.02
duties of school superintendents in 303
303.01 is the is the substantive duties
of school boards
um and we also have to take a look at
RSA
194-c colon 4. that's the duties of
superintendents
um and if we look at 194 C4 it's um
recruitment supervision evaluation of
Staff Development review and evaluation
of curriculum coordination and
implementation of various curricula
provisions of Staff training compliance
with laws regulations pupil achievement
assessment through uh grading and state
and National assessment procedures So
currently if we're talking about sort of
the the
the operational aspects of a school
board you know we say the school board
governs the district and I think you've
been to some of our trainings budget
policy collective bargaining evaluate
the superintendent compliance with their
right to no law um public information
programs things of that nature
conversely the superintendent when I
when I say the superintendent and
obviously some of this is going to be
delegated to the administrative team
special ed director business manager
principals are more responsible for sort
of the day-to-day operations of this of
the school bus if a school or it could
see the school buses I'm getting out of
my first example the school district so
if a bus is running late and a
constituent calls the parent that's all
well and good but chances are it's going
to be the superintendent that's going to
be in touch with the curriculum
coordinator if the boiler blows up and
there's no heat in that day I mean yes
the school board should be informed of
that but it's going to be the
superintendent working with the facility
guy or the maintenance guy or whoever
the contractor to come in and get it
fixed so if we look at again if we look
at rsa194 C4 the superintendent services
and then look at that in conjunction
with Department of Education rule 302
those are the administrative
superintendent responsibilities and just
looking at sort of
302.01
superintendent Shall Serve as the
executive officer of the local school
districts within the SAU be responsible
for the overall Administration
such local school district Services
shall be included but not limited to the
following areas Personnel Finance
curriculum instruction assessment you
know they put that they put that in the
duties of the superintendents and the
doors because as I think I mentioned
when when I gave my testimony last
January I believe this bill was heard
that's you know again School boards are
again we've had some of the conversation
here school board members are not
educational experts we have
chemistry teachers and we have social
studies teachers and we have you know
things of things of that nature I guess
the other concern that sort of nhsba has
in retirement I don't want to belabor
this point either when we're talking
about school board sort of approving the
curriculum and the textbooks and I think
representative Moffett you've certainly
touched on this and can coordination
with representative Mullen you'd be
asking the school board member to be a
Content expert in everything that's
being taught in that school from pre-k
to AP Calculus we are 12th year of high
school that's a tall task for for an
average School Board member you know to
your to the extent representative Hobson
when you were on the school board you
get a concern about from a constituent
you know we would always say at nhsba
that's all that's great listen to the
concern listen to the complaint but it's
not necessarily an individual school
boards member job to quote unquote solve
the problem because the law doesn't
necessarily give you Authority directed
to the appropriate person is a you know
that back to the teacher back to the
principal back to the superintendent if
it's something that you know may rise to
a board level issue a hearing of some
sort or a review you're going to
non-public section to talk with the
parents that that may that it may get to
that point but initially there's sort of
a chain of communication as I believe
somebody over on this side mentioned so
um I think that's a long-winded answer
to the simple question of who's
responsible for what you know we have
the Department of Education rules
um that speak to some of these things in
coordination with RSA 189 1A and then
the superintendents you know
responsibility over the educational
programming if you will and 194 C4
oh thank you I just wanted to make sure
I understood
um so uh the School Board Association
position
um vau would be that
um uh curriculum and textbooks
um would not necessarily be approved by
the school board thank you for the
question uh chairman cordially I believe
my testimony last time said if a school
board wants to do that they can under
current law you don't need the the sort
of enabling legislation or the enabling
language that's in that's in the bill
and I think I also said you know some
School Board some school boards probably
are involved in in looking at the books
and getting reports from the curriculum
coordinator and the superintendent and
other school boards aren't I don't think
school boards are precluded from doing
that right now under current law
thank you
um representative bum
thank you uh I was on the school board
also and we approved curriculum and we
also told the superintendent to get rid
of some curriculum right I mean we had
an American history book and I didn't
know about it until my granddaughter who
was in the ninth grade at the time
showed it to me I said what
and it was completely biased it wasn't
no American history said so so put two
sides and whatnot then found written by
some organ Professor you know of course
so we got rid of that book the next year
so yeah I mean we approved curriculum we
hadn't presented to us and yet we didn't
have to read the thing and just like
said yeah we listened to a testimony and
that's what we listen right right but
yeah we can't read everything unless
your kid brings it up to you sure but
yeah but yeah we approved all our
curriculum the other challenge too
um just from a sort of an operational
standpoint
um what I would be concerned about is
you know curriculum changing every time
there's a new school board election
right you know it's just you know it
they they go back and forth we all we
all know that you know you can't and
curriculum is expensive too textbooks
are not cheap the software programs are
not cheap you know so you know you have
a curriculum you don't like or the new
the quote-unquote new school board
doesn't necessarily like the new school
board members all it takes is one vote
to flip you spend a hundred thousand
dollars last year on map books or
whatever it might be and you know you're
gonna you're gonna switch that up and
spend another hundred thousand dollars
in two years because the vote flipped
when one person you know change sides so
there's just sort of a an operational
aspect of that too that we should be
very very mindful of as well
yeah this is like every five years we do
it and this was one year left though
right it wasn't that much of a deal and
that was the only time that that you
know I mean what I what I would tell
school boards too to anybody that home
that that's listening you know if if
you've got questions about this put it
on the put it on this agenda say I want
a report from the superintendent the
assistant superintendent and or the
curriculum coordinator if you have one
how talk talk to the school board about
the process that the administration goes
through for reviewing and making a
presentation or a recommendation to the
school board
um you know and and there are other ways
around that as well too some boards some
boards may have like a curriculum
committee where it's not the full board
but you've got one School Board member
who sits in with the principals and the
superintendent so there's at least
somebody on the board that has a sense
that's going back and then they can come
back and report to the full board as
well too
yeah
thank you thank you
um maybe we can to the uh next section
section three being on line 24.
um
which discusses uh District policies uh
conduct of board meetings
any
um comments on on those uh approval of
the budget Etc I think they're pretty
uh yes uh I have I on that page uh
certainly we would all like to set as a
goal that everyone conformed to
standards of ethical Behavior whether
you're a member of the school board or a
member of the public but
um how do we Define that what
that to me is a very sort of vague
my language and someone else's language
may be uh on two different planes right
and what I consider not conforming to
the standards of ethical Behavior
somebody else might
uh I believe my intent there was many
boards have a an Ethics policy for
conduct
um by board members so that was the
intent there
um anything else on that section
three
uh yes so are we going over onto the
next page as well sure we can address
any of those
okay uh line seven
public input at multiple times during
board meetings
I don't know how a board would
accomplish that I don't know what
multiple times means does that mean
twice does it mean six times is there a
time limit uh
so that would be the next thing that I
would I would question right and I I
think we did have legislation that we
did pass last year that dealt with that
topic so I think that that's pretty much
in statute so are you suggesting that it
be struck from here right that it would
not be needed at this point all right
thank you
um
someone could certainly modify what we
passed last year to provide some other
language absolutely the process allows
for it yep
further discussion
um
uh I was wondering about the feelings on
classroom visitations
this just recommends a policy on
classroom visitations not any specific
requirements
foreign
I think that that
um there should be a policy on classroom
visitations
um if you you know it it isn't an open
book like that uh parents can call in
the morning and come into the classroom
or just walk into the classroom I think
that's
that's a dangerous situation you you
might have a parent who's really
agitated from who knows what
um you know certainly the vast majority
of parents are are calm and cool and
they really like the way things are
going but the small percentage that
might come in and really create havoc
and
um be very disruptive so I think think
of policy um and I I think our school
had a policy on on school visitation as
as well as people coming in to talk uh
in our classes uh you know outside
things and I I just I would say that um
in order for a school to function that
probably is something that that happens
in most of the school districts
um I I can't imagine a school district
that didn't have a policy of some type
thank you
represent Paul
is that a question can we just back up
to line nine for a minute
um what does that look like
policy to promote parental engagement
you just
what would that say
uh
and I realize it says student
achievement progress but what is it
I'm just curious what a policy like that
um I I believe
um
as the drafter of this
um the idea was that we needed to uh
encourage parental engagement it's a
fundamental from everyone from the
teachers unions to uh
um policy uh people that we need to have
parents involved with the school and so
it was just a really more a statement
that there should be
that
goal and there should be policies
related to that which could depend on
the school and the school board what
their feelings were and how they wanted
to structure how that parental
engagement was conducted we've had
legislation
numerous times about parental engagement
I remember one bill
uh in particular
um was just a commission to study
um uh engaging parents with uh
non-academic subjects when they were
going to be discussed
um and um
mental health was a key consideration
there and unfortunately that commission
was not uh passed that legislation for
the commission was not passed but I
think parental engagement was a very
important topic and so that was just
really a statement as much as anything
in in there
it
um yes
when you were talking about something
not needed
Etc
I thought the intent of this was to lay
out in one place
so that a school board member could go
and look and say okay what are my
responsibilities and go through and see
what they are
so just because we have a law someplace
else that clarifies that
you know public content
sorry
um for instance what that means I I
still think it needs to be in here
because this is I see it as the general
guide am I mistaken in that
um I I think that was
um one of the things I was trying to
accomplish and certainly
um if there was something else uh
elsewhere in statute I mean from 194 for
instance
um you could say in here pursuant to
Etc yeah that would be the thing to do
right
representative and and I guess that
speaks to my point
um earlier that first of all I'd like to
see side by side with the rules of of
that are currently in the the doe as
well as the statute so so that we see it
all lined up number one what is
currently there and and what is in this
particular
um bill but also the fact that that when
we make statues then it goes gel car and
the doe then makes the rules and it
would seem to me that it would be
instead of in statue
what you're talking about should be
from the doe in the rules combining all
the things giving the direction to the
school board to the superintendent
from what the statutes are and that then
the school boards Association also would
take that as a listing and I'm sure they
um in their training go through what is
the responsibilities and answer
questions about the board but
um to to keep piling more in this book
and to put more regulation
on school on just Public Schools we're
not doing this for Charters we're not
doing this for private or any schools
that accept our taxpayer money but
um for just Public Schools I think
I think we need to really file it down
and and see where it really belongs
whether it belongs in statutes or it
belongs to doe rules
uh I would I would just say that there
my way of thinking there should be
nothing in rules that does not refer
back to statute I think it is a problem
to have
um the executive branch developing rules
that are go beyond statute
yes I I
with all due respect have a different
interpretation of the process and that
is that the statute is sort of the
overarching umbrella and then the
specifics are in rules
so
um right but I think the cumbersomeness
of putting job descriptions into statute
and that's really what we're doing we're
putting the job description of a school
board member into statute I mean where
do we go next are we then going to put
the principal's job into statute the
teacher's job the state police Trooper
the uh
the toll booth worker I I don't know
where we stop if
my my understanding is the RSA States
the obvious that it is it it is the
overarching kind of broad definition and
then the fine tuning is done in the in
the rules
um maybe we could keep on going down
um the list
um uh next would be uh transparency and
there were a number of things listed
under that beginning on line 14 on page
two
um any comments on
any of those items there are six of them
I believe acceptance of contracts
posting of manifests
um posting of curriculum
Etc
representative moffatt thank you Mr uh
yes and I do want to Circle back real
quick and just say I agree with
representative mullen's concerns on the
uh the standards of ethical Behavior I
flagged the same question with the same
point on that
um and on the line right above uh
uh
where it says to allow classroom
visitations that's that's uh through we
have a Bill Bill I'm involved with some
of you already are aware of that
um the issue of being too prescriptive I
think that was kind of Representative
mullen's Point that's I share the same
concern in terms of being too too
prescriptive in statute uh I I think we
should be wary of that now the the other
bill that we're going to deal with later
this month on classroom visitations and
classroom transparency
that bill does not it was that was a
prime sponsor that build is not
prescribed any specific policy or or
funding all it does is ask for a report
in the 10 of that is I've gone over many
times is just to get boards locally to
talk about or address transparency
recording classroom visitation policies
so on line 14 uh where in just to back
up real quick one more comment on that
the problem I have with the work with
the wording of uh the online 12 Section
3 developing and implementing a policy
to allow classroom visitations now I'm
big on transparency I think you all know
that and I I think classroom visitations
should be
the part of the mix but the problem with
saying that we sh we will Implement a
policy to allow classroom visitations
now if that's in statute I can see some
cases where students in IEP or there's
some unique circumstances where the they
don't would not want it would not be
appropriate for someone anyone to come
in and watch that instruction in a
unique case but if this were to pass as
worded then it would be in statute that
by law the the districts would have to
allow classroom visitations so if you're
tracking that that's just my question
I'm just concerned about being overly
prescriptive so on line 14 voting on all
contracts acceptance of gifts and grants
uh you know gifts and you know a major
Grant is a major Grant but sometimes in
the short term you know all kinds of
gifts or or things come to a a school
office
and by again if this is law there would
there have to be a board meeting to
accept a gift of a few hundred dollars
to to improve an athletic field I that
that's just my concerns being overly
prescriptive if if you're tracking that
thank you thank you
representative cordelli do you happen to
know in terms of uh collective
bargaining
whether or not voting requiring that all
votes on voting on all contracts I don't
being done in public
um
do you happen to know whether or not
that would stand in challenge to any of
the collective bargaining procedures
I would think that it would um not doing
it in a vote in public but in a
non-public meeting or something like
that
would be a violation 91a
right right but it doesn't I'm not
talking about voting on are we accepting
the contract or not I'm talking about
you know in collective bargaining
when
teacher negotiators and School Board
negotiators are meeting
are those considered to be public
meetings I don't believe so there there
have been
um bills put forward I think to expand
some of those meetings as being public
yeah so I'm just but not well that was
that was my understanding my
understanding was that those were not so
when you say voting on all contracts
that's a little nebulous uh in terms of
if you've got a if you've got school
district negotiators and teacher
negotiators sitting around and they say
okay well can we all agree on this well
how do you feel about that let's take a
vote on it is I I think this would be a
board we're talking about uh
responsibility to the school board so
this would be a school board vote on a
contract
okay I I I guess what I'm saying is that
I saw room for interpretation in that
language so that might be problematic
thank you
Christina
um I also see kind of problematic again
I guess with the over prescriptiveness
of posting uh invoices on a regular
basis on the district website
um
again we have a business manager you
know all school districts super
supervisory units have a business
manager
um certainly the school board
um has access to these invoices uh but
to post it on the district website I
just think is
uh
Overkill over prescriptive
um
yeah thank you
um any other comments on any of those
um I was wondering about posting of uh
um professional development topics for
instance
yeah I I really
um don't see the intent of this I mean
um
the school districts now offer their
there's teachers of professional
development usually as part of the
pre-school year or post-school year
but other times particularly Specialists
uh that deal in
well like I did in health and physical
education or art music or special
education
um we often went to workshops that were
um not spot not directly sponsored by
the school and I just I I don't know
what the intent is of that to um
have it posted on the district website
what what it's it's part of our
professional development part of our
um certification okay thank you
um how about uh the next section
um number six on line 23
um that talks about posting enrollment
achievement information
um or a link
to the department of educational website
which the new
um I report a facility on the Department
of Education has a great wealth of
information about
um schools school districts ranging from
academics to financial
information
would would you see just a school
district website just having a link for
information to that at the Department of
Education website
I I would definitely
um say a link to the department is is uh
really you know something that should be
there
um my biggest
uh complaint I guess or or
comment about that particular thing that
particular statement is that I really
bristle every time we have this per
pupil cost because what happens is that
somebody in the district comes in they
have a special ed student that's a
hundred thousand dollars and
um all of a sudden everybody in the
school per pupil cost is like Sky High
and um it really that if you are just
taking the total budget of the school
dividing it by the total number of
pupils and saying that that's the cost
per student that's not an accurate
vision of what um actually is the cost
per student at a school right I I think
that if you look at the Department of
Education website there is
um information on how they calculate uh
per pure cost there are exclusions from
that in their calculation
I I know I'm not on this committee but I
was at the one about I report and I
report isn't the name of the isn't the
name of the program though that's one of
the subcategories and I can't remember
the name of the I platform okay okay
yeah
and I agree that definitely should be on
every school district's website because
that that is an excellent
so
fascinating the amount of information
they're making available there
um
how about the last section the uh
requirement of a survey end of year
survey
um I I will note that I I did have an
amendment at the end of the uh
discussion on this bill that that
removed that section but uh just
throwing that open to see what the
subcommittee's thoughts were on an end
of year survey of parents
good enough
I would not be in support of it but
um what is the intent of that anyway
what what do you see at the end game
um we did uh put in place for
um tax credit scholarship
program and for Education Freedom
accounts the requirement for Parental
surveys
is the parental survey in those issues
cover all these areas
it for the the ones we currently do for
the fa and for the uh education tax
credit I honestly I have to go back and
look
representative Lakers
how can you tell how you're doing if you
don't get an evaluation
I mean whenever we did whenever I did
any kind of training or when I was in
college at the end of classes
we did an evaluation that had a lot of
this stuff on it and that's how you got
feedback to know how to get better and
so that would be to me the purpose of
this is so that the schools know what's
going on and know how to get better
Mr chair yeah did they post your uh
survey online
uh for some yes they did
represent Mullen uh not only
am I okay with a parent survey uh I know
that some school districts already do
this and uh I would think that it would
be equally as important to get this
information from the students in in the
building
and then okay yes
thank you to share uh yes I agree with
Rob Simone again I I think uh it may be
not quite in sync with representative
Hall in this uh I think parental surveys
uh I support that engagement of parents
involving parents getting input for
parents uh I I think is important uh my
only concern is as with any survey or
instrument uh you know who's putting it
together you know as you all know uh I'm
sure
some surveys can have leading questions
and they can the the questions can
invite certain responses uh for
ideological reasons and so that that's
my only concern parent involvement yes
uh the student involvement piece
um again I uh I in theory it's great to
allow the students as well but I some of
these students are not that well
informed or educated and I I'd be a
little nervous about
student surveys but I know some some
places do that some boards have student
members uh which is different from a
student survey I anyway uh that
parents yes students in some way I'm not
sure how thanks thank you I would just
just a comment uh representative Moffett
that uh in my experience we have had
difficulty getting surveys back from
parents so so I I think it would have to
be something that was looked at
exceptionally carefully to look at those
student uh the parent sample size and
whether or not the amount of return
would even have the survey be considered
to be reliable or valid
good good point
just point out that
um really since
um
this bill was drafted the Department of
Education now does an annual survey
called 603
Bright Futures survey I think is the
title of it that includes
Provisions for
parents staff teachers and the community
for all to answer the survey in a
complete a question questions related to
their areas really
including special needs I remember
looking at specifically
um so you know I'm not sure if that
might take the place of uh requiring in
school districts to do that individually
but um that is something someone could
take a look at uh to see if they feel
um that might replace a school school
district survey
uh and so is the time winding down for
this bill
um
I'm just I've heard several areas that
uh maybe there could be some agreement
that might
be the subject of future legislation as
a recommendation from the uh
subcommittee but also I guess start out
with uh 1137 itself if anyone feels that
um
it should be brought back as future
legislation or maybe just components of
it
representative Lakers
I like the idea of this obviously it
sounds like we need a few tweaking and
wording and leaving this and that out
but if we so in our recommendation
in our report that we send forward
should we not have as notes that you
know those the things we talked about
right
and and so
I think moving this for you know saying
yes this should go forward but these are
the things these are the issues that we
think should be fixed changed you know
whatever or kept in or
you know whatever does that
make sense yeah thank you
um and and I uh representative Lucas
will be surprised to hear this would go
in the other direction and say that
straight up should we go forward with 11
37 no because there are too many
unanswered questions with regards to the
side by side with the Ed 300 rules and
what's currently in statute and
uh some of the areas that we talked
about that we think may have gotten
covered in other bills last session so I
would say no to 11 37 uh that we would
not go forward with this bill
and then certainly it's the chair's
purview as to whether or not you include
information uh regarding what potential
legislation may come out of the bill
one that I definitely heard was a link
to the Department of Education
information system my platform
I think you know some of these things I
think again
um don't need to be in statute I think
uh the for example the link I think
that's something that could come out of
doe that here's this link and we would
like to have this you know on all the I
mean I just think a lot of this that
we're going over
uh is either already in statute or is
something that the doe needs to if it
needs to be all put together in one
package then the doe needs to do that
um whether it's done with a side by side
I
I just again feel like we've we've gone
through this it's it's over prescriptive
we don't really know uh how the new
legislation fits into it we don't know
uh really how the rules that are
established by the doe line up with 189
194 the ones that that cover
superintendents and School Board
directions and if we want it all in one
package it seems to me that the doe
needs to do that and that some of the
things that we agreed on for example uh
the survey
um that that it's just a it's something
that comes out of the doe as a
suggestion to the school districts and
see how that goes I mean some school
districts may be
you know have thousands and thousands
and thousands of students and others
have 80. you know so
immersion of Vegas
it's my experience and from what we've
seen here or what I've seen here over
the last four years is that there are a
lot of things that school districts
don't do if you don't put it in statute
and so saying suggestion from the DOE
that you know some schools are really
good about that but others it's not me
it's they're not told they have to it's
one more thing they don't do it so and
saying oh but these are the rules and so
we need to fit our what we're doing to
the rules it's the other way around we
say this is what we want to happen and
they write the rules to enact what we
say is going to happen it's not we look
at the rules and say oh what should we
pass so I think we need to get the horse
in the cart in the right order
my my point wasn't that we should look
at the rules and then you know let them
do stuff it it's the the series of what
our obligations are and what the
prescriptions are at different levels
and the fact that we
we need to get have if we're going to
make a good decision we need to have
good information input right good input
to us and by having some sort of listing
of all this material together
um rather than try to go
piece by piece on the internet and find
rule 300 whatever and not knowing that
maybe
300.25 exists someplace else we need to
see it all together and until we see
that all together there's no way I would
I would vote to to say go ahead with
this legislation
thank you Mr chairman I just wonder if
maybe it might be useful to the school
systems if we at least put a reference
in here to the need to survey the
families who do not speak English and
make some effort to reach out to that
sub-population which is growing
considerably in our communities and that
it usually at least put it on the list
so that it's not overlooked that is my
concern
thank you representative Lucas
I guess when I was saying go ahead with
this legislation I wasn't
I wasn't saying this bill the way it is
now I was saying that the intent of this
bill I think we should go ahead with but
if we're going to do that yeah we're
going to want to look at the side by
side like you said see what wording
needs to be changed I mean that's part
of what we've been doing here I've been
writing notes all over this about what
things
if we do something like this this coming
year what things need to be changed and
that was what I was saying needs to go
in the notes so to me it was not this
bill as worded but this bill has
intended with
notes these changes or these
recommendations or whatever that's I
think what I was that's what I was
thinking
in in reference to the discussion about
uh
other areas of Statute
such as 194c as was mentioned by Barrett
Christina
would you see
expansion of
the duties Section 1 189 1A
to include
some of those other
areas of rsas
with just a for instance
um
I can't think of a specific but uh
referring to
um something and saying pursuant to
another section of Statute 194c
Etc underneath
um
expanded duties list
so that because it goes back to
codification of the law the rsas and
there is a legislation I think to look
at recodification of some of this coming
next year but if we're to have a section
about
duties for the school board should we
combine in this one section other
sections such as from 194c here with
just references to
um
those other areas
I certainly think that anything that you
move forward with
should of course in consider 194c and
the Ed rules uh so that you're not
putting language forward that's at Cross
purposes to each other so that whatever
happens it's clarifying rather than
muddying so uh but I certainly would not
be able to
um
to say that I would recommend moving
forward with anything more General than
a clarification of the roles of school
it's you know because I'm I how can we
improve anything if we don't see it
okay
um
quickly uh yeah quickly
um one of one of the things that
surprised me when I first got elected
first got on the education committee was
that this book is like somebody building
a house and just keeps building you know
little rooms and little nooks and
crannies and and none of them are
connected and that's that's maybe the
only the the one overlying thing that I
think is important is that
for for the clarity for the people that
are doing the work in education and for
the clarity for the people that are
legislating we need to have some some
organization rather than pursuant to
this and to pursue into that and jumping
all over in in the law book
um it's really uh amazing to me how this
how this whole thing works
um
as a general common as to what I'm
hearing
um and please correct me if I'm
not stating it correctly but
um 11 37 I'm feeling on the subcommittee
saying should not proceed
um as as written but if there is to be
similar legislation that
um discusses the duties of school boards
it should be uh
including references to the r as other
rsas as sort of a re-codification of the
duties of school board so that they're
all in one place and that any references
here to others areas of Statute should
be specified such as references to some
Duty that might be listed in 194c or
other rsas
peace with one with one elaboration on
that representative cordelli I just
think that care needs to be taken to
make sure that we're not putting
something into statute that works in
opposition to what is in Ed rules so I
think those Ed rules need to be
considered somewhere
thank you
uh represent Moffett
teams here uh yeah which you just said I
I agree with which you just gave
expression to I also agree with
representative leckis uh I I think I
understand the intent of this and I
support the overall intent of better
defining School Board duties and also
empowering parents I think that's part
of the intent of this uh but this is to
me
um that said this is almost like an
Omnibus type thing there are so many
pieces to this in our job which we're
doing is to look at every piece and
brainstorm it and what if it and
Murphy's Law rep uh and one other
comment um just to pick out online 26
about conducting an annual end of year
parental survey with results to be
posted in the district website
um I like that idea in principle the the
problem I have though is that if a
district doesn't do that then they're in
violation of the law and somebody in the
district will come to school or meeting
to say to the administrators you know
you're breaking the law you didn't do
what the law said they said well we'll
try to get to it and my concern is that
if we have at least prescriptive
requirements that get ignored uh all too
often already uh I think it results in a
little bit of uh disdain for the law uh
you know you know you know nothing's
going to happen if we don't do this
because it's we don't agree with it
anyway nobody enforces it so I I'm not
sure what the enforcement mechanism
would be for districts that don't comply
with this law or this requirements I
just think we need to be careful about
what we put in the Statue and make sure
that you know it it's taken seriously
and it's going to actually happen
Mr chair yes I I think uh to follow up
on Mr on representative moffett's uh
comment I think you know
um there's a whole thing about the
consent of the governed you know that
that when you make laws and you may you
make regulations uh the more people that
you involve and the more parties and
that you involve in that decision
um certainly uh helps for it to be
implemented if everybody agrees that
it's a good law and and something that
they can actually Implement and
something that's meaningful for them
so uh I think one of the things we need
to look at is again
one of the reasons
I'm on this committee is that as a
teacher as a person involved in
education public education I was
continually distressed by the political
influence and the political intrusion
into what was happening and the the
over-regulation and underfunding of
public schools and we just keep putting
piling more regulations and more
regulations on to public schools
and maybe that's the way that's why
Charter Schools kind of broke off is
because they they didn't want to be as
regulated as public schools
but until you have consent of the Govern
so so you've got school districts that
are overburdened by political policies
they've got overburdened by regulations
they're trying to do a job with kids
with limited in many cases very limited
funds limited we were having problems
getting teachers now because of our
whole situation and just to say okay
we're going to do a felony conviction on
a superintendent and if the if they
don't follow the regulations that we
think are important
um you know one of the things about this
particular bill as it moves forward or
the intent of it is it should be a
commission or a committee and and invite
people from the the school boards
Association and invite superintendents
and invite teachers and maybe even
students to come in and testify and have
input into what they they think I mean
we just can't keep piling stuff on
public schools
thank you um so a recommendation
from this subcommittee to the full
committee
um would it be fair to say that we do
not support moving 1137 forward as
future legislation as written
but
we do not
object to the idea that
um the duties of school boards could be
better defined in statute and if there
is future legislation to do that that
189 1A
include references to other areas of the
RSA that Define statutes
so that their 189 would be more a a
listing with references to other
areas of Statute so that they're more
centralized in one place
with regards to representative moffett's
comments about this being an Omnibus
Bill and representative Tanner's
Brilliance at suggesting a study
committee or commission to look at the
countless aspects that are in the bill
um
uh yeah I think that it's fair to say
that 1137 should probably die a
respectful death and uh that
moving forward any legislation should
consider existing statutes the Ed rules
and uh I would certainly be in support
of a study committee or
Commission
uh looking at the duties of school board
members and whether or not they are
adequately defined
as is
um could we say
um that
um there was uh
uh I won't speak for everyone but a
unanimous thought that it should not
move forward as is but there could be a
better definition in statute of the
duties of a school board in a
centralized location with respect to
other areas of the rsas
and that some members think that a a
study
committee uh Bill might be a solution
moving forward
so
I'll speak for myself enjoy I could live
with that okay
okay good everyone can live with that
um and uh please when we're uh in a full
committee
um if I misstate what I just stated uh
please correct me
do you need a motion on this
representative cordelli
um it would probably be a good idea
all right I move that uh we do not move
forward with House Bill 1137
and that any uh future recommendations
be brought to with the Full House and
committee
um well it would
any future legislation
um would come to the Full House
committee anyway right but with regards
to the meeting on the 24th that we oh
yes right now Foundation fourth to the
yes right yeah okay
all right yeah
I'm not yes you know she is
yeah okay
um everyone in representative Muppet
discussion yes you know real quick uh I
agree with what the chair just said I
agree mostly with what representative
Mullen just said I just want to in
addition to the notion of a commission
or committee or whatever I I do want to
just say that we have a filing period in
November those who might still be around
and
um rather than have a which we could do
as well I have a commission or committee
whatever on the on the totality of
school board expectations but there are
a lot of pieces of this that many of us
liked for example just one example
posting all curriculum and competencies
on the district website that largely
happens already doesn't happen
everywhere but if there were an LSR or
Bill that simply said something like
that uh that would be more
uh chewable what's the word I'm looking
for digestible then then then yeah
digestible than this so I just want to
make the point that
um the the many good pieces of this I
think uh some of them could come forward
and should come forward uh after
November
um but
in smaller chunks so to speak uh thank
you Mr chair
Okay so are we we're all good with
that
okay great
um thank you very much and um some of us
are sticking around for uh 1164.
um and I
oh I'm sorry yeah 1664. thank you
um and I have as the members of that
subcommittee uh cordelli Hobson Baum
Porter and Tanner
great I'm gonna take a take a take five
minutes
I think we just did
I I think we have uh all our
subcommittee members here
uh cordelli Hobson foam supporter Tanner
so
um maybe we can get started uh I know
um some people have time constraints
um this interim study bill is uh HB
1664.
requiring certain non-public schools or
education service providers that accept
public funds to perform background
checks on all employees and volunteers
um
so
this
legislation I think the prime sponsor
was uh representative Porter
um
uh did
yes that's what I was going to ask okay
so thank you for letting me speak to
this Mr chair my concern was and Still
Remains
um
the ability of Bad actors and there are
some
to figure out a way
to infiltrate
lessons uh School rooms uh
prendapods that kind of stuff
um
for not very good reasons
um and we I know we spent a lot of time
dealing with what background checks have
to be done and what would would
constitute not allowing somebody to get
there their teacher credential but if I
understood correctly from the testimony
that we heard during the year that
foreign
if someone doesn't have to be certified
to do a job
um the Department of Education only does
those background checks on people who
are looking to get teacher credentials
they don't have any authority to do
background checks on other people
the only those that are getting a
credential
um
I know that when I ran my preschool
kindergarten
if
a high school kid came down to work with
us which they often did and they were
over a certain age they had to have a
background check because they were
coming in okay I didn't take public
money when I was there
I'm just really this really worries me
um because I have heard some really bad
stories and not saying that there's
everybody but I know you read the papers
and it's it's
it's not just it's clergy it's Boy Scout
leaders it's Girl Scout leaders there
seems to be so many places where these
um people who want to get access to
young children infiltrate so that they
can do that and if we're going to be
sending money from our tax base
to pay for services that someone is
providing in their home or in the
prendapod or you know after school
program somewhere
they need to we need to make sure that
we're not allowing those kinds of people
to have access to our young people so I
know that there was an issue
um
and there were several other bills along
this line
there were problems with what kind of
um
background check could be done who could
who had the authority to get the FBI one
and that sort of thing
and that we were going to there was a
commission that was set up from
um
representative McGuire had set up that's
a little on this draft note like so I'm
really hoping that when when you
consider this bill that you consider
that this will be looked into next term
I recommend that something like this
will be investigated to assure me when
I'm home watching from from the video
um that I'm not going to be starting to
hear
horror stories of young children being
abused because of not having nobody knew
that they were this or that that was
dealing with them so thank you
representative bone
thank you representative anyway the
problem with this is homeschool a group
of homeschool
students can get together and invite
somebody in to speak to them
people are there the parents are there
or whatever
you're not going to be able to get
people to come in and speak if they have
to have a criminal background check and
the point is also on private schools
altogether I mean a lawsuit can put a
private school out of business there are
going to be more of a criminal
background check than public schools you
can't put a public school out of
business a private school you can
Catholic schools you can put out a
business and insurance companies won't
won't cover you unless you've done a
criminal background check on Catholic
schools so this is even less than that
this is inviting somebody in to speak
about a different subject to your own
home school students so why do they need
to have a criminal background check
you're not going to get people to come
in and discuss things so to me this goes
way overboard and as part of the do away
with EFA thank you
yes okay so one of the things that um
when we ran the preschool kindergarten
we had to get so many credit hours
um of in-service training every year and
it created a problem when we were only
work had our school only open you know
so many hours a week and but the health
and human services department and their
rules specified that if someone was
working five hours or less with the
children in a week they didn't have to
go through that so it's you could have a
bill that would say that somebody who's
working X number of times x number of
time with children as a volunteer
doesn't need to have the background
check okay so I think we could overcome
that representative and you know I don't
think this is against efas this is child
protection I mean this is child
protection
we have these rules for public schools
for child protection but if we don't
have these rules for other kinds of
schools in the state or other kinds of
educational opportunities we're
abandoning that and and it's
it's scary to me it's scary to me so I'm
sure that we could have some kind of
adaption adaptions made to make it
doable for someone who just comes in for
an hour or two or gives a lecture it
comes in for a puppet show or that kind
of thing but if someone's working day in
day out in a small group of children
with a small group of children by
themselves I think they need to make we
need to make sure that that person is
safe to have her own children and if
we're sending the money to do it we need
to make sure that they're safe around
children so it's not against EFA you
know it really isn't it's a it's a child
safety thing representative Tanner thank
you well after working and representing
Mullen knows this too after working in
the background check realm it is
unbelievable but there are some things
that that um for example camps all camps
have to have all their counselors
background checked and camps can get
sued and put out of business too but
obviously it was put into statute so
that every Camp particularly does that
um the other thing that I think is is uh
should be known in this whole realm is
that the state actually tried to Define
volunteer when when would a volunteer
like someone coming into a home school
school or coming into a classroom have
to get a background check
and this the state at that time the
safety issue was that if if someone came
in on a volunteer basis for
a certain amount of time but also that
they had no time alone that with
students so the volunteer came in the
speaker came in and there were other
adults in the room as as representative
Baum has described then that person did
not need a background check and that
that's already in in our statutes as a
description of volunteers
what I'm concerned about and and just
recently you know in my area where now
you can get PE credit you know mowing
Grandma's lawn or whatever but I'm sure
some of the people get PE credits uh for
uh being on soccer teams and doing
soccer programs and we've just had a
report come out with
uh horrible news about
um how some of these private soccer
clubs that have been set up and that um
are particularly for young women and
girls how uh destructive they are and
how there's been quite a bit of abuse
and they're totally unregulated and one
of the things about public schools and
and even Charter Schools is that
um you've got a system of oversight and
assessment you've got
um you know you never nothing is going
to be
99.9 sure we know that if a background
check is done today
tomorrow who knows what that person
might do what we're trying to do is do
the best we can to provide safety for
students on a regular basis whether it's
the bus driver
cafeteria worker uh the volunteer that
comes in that actually spends one to one
time on unsupervised time with students
those people need to have background
checks so that we have some sort of
issue about it and I think that saying
that well you know parents are parents
are the oversight parents are the
assessment of uh when the student does
prender when they uh go on the soccer
team or they you know whatever these
other places that they can get their
education
that's that's fine and good but parents
don't have the time to nor the ability
to do background checks it's kind of
like when I go in to buy meat at the
store
I assume that meat is going to be safe
it's been tested the there's reg there's
government regulations on it that I'm
not immediately exposed to you know some
sort of poisonous
um meat uh rotten meat or something
inside it
um and when it does happen and it does
happen once in a while
there's government reporting that
catches it and then
uh you know finds out about it we know
that for example St Paul's had a
horrible situation going on and that
um you know I and I'm sure their
background checks are like Stellar now
at this point
um but
we need to have some sort of checks and
balances and we need to keep Kids Safe
And there are Bad actors out there that
are that see an opportunity and and I
think I think this is this is needed
thank you
um
I guess I'll comment at this point
um I am uh
troubled by the uh home education
um Provisions
um in this bill
um as referenced by representative boehm
um and that
could be interpreted as requiring a
background check to educate your own
children
um there are uh very many
home education cooperatives where
families get together and
um you know children go to a cooperative
for lessons on various subjects
schools now micro schools doing that
same thing that that Do Do by background
checks so I think we're going in a very
bad Direction
um to include that in any language
we had
excellent testimony from Diana Fenton
when we first heard this bill about the
ongoing efforts of the Department of
Education
with relation to background checks and
they're ongoing
efforts to expand and Define that with
volunteers for instance as was mentioned
I'm also troubled by us getting involved
with non-public schools
I do have an email that I received um
last year I think after after we heard
this bill from the superintendent of
Catholic schools David T ball
um and in his email to me he said I
can't speak for all non-public schools
but our Catholic schools have to conduct
background checks for all Personnel
coaches and volunteers
we have to do this for our safe
environment protocols
and ministerial conduct policies
first and foremost also insurance
companies do require it and yes schools
who are accredited have to meet
standards for these checks as well
so you know I think that um
trying to include non-public schools in
um
provision and statute here for this
um is uh
um is wrong I think that it's already
being done
um and I don't think that the government
needs to put its hand into uh every pie
out there in terms of private soccer
clubs I don't know if that is something
that we want to get involved in here I
know my kids played little league and
had figure skating coaches and you know
that was our responsibility as parents
we didn't require
the little league coach to have a
background check before we allowed our
kid to play
Little League Baseball
so I think that this
legislation goes beyond where we should
be going
but
that we all are concerned with safe 50
of children and I think that that is a
responsibility in terms of our public
and public charter schools but that it's
already being done for
non-public schools
[Music]
representative Porter thank you Mr chair
um first of all the soccer clubs aren't
getting our tax dollars okay second and
I'm this is one of the reasons why this
is so concerning to me
we hear all the time about the nice
things that go on home schools and I
have worked with excellent homeschool
students when I worked for the Youth
advisory Council I am not against it but
in my town
we had a situation
where the children were removed from
school brought to homeschool
and were being sexually abused by their
stepfather and because there was no way
that the school could check on them and
there was no protection for those girls
those girls suffered and finally one of
them escaped she ran away to the
neighbors the neighbors helped her to
get away and she went to Florida
and she filed a suit against her father
and stepfather and she ended up he ends
he is in jail now
so that makes me really concerned about
what happens to children when there's no
one checking on them when they're with a
bad actor
I I can't imagine the life that that
family of young girls was living
but it couldn't have been very good it's
no one there for them there was no one
to protect them that little girl at 14
had to run away to a neighbor to get the
help that she needed
to escape that situation I don't want
that kind of thing to happen to our
young people and if we're we're able to
say that the private schools are already
doing background checks fantastic then
then if this bill won't be an issue for
them
but these other opportunities need to be
addressed they can't be ignored
I just I feel very strongly about it and
Miss representative Bowman doesn't have
anything to do with efas it's got to do
with what happened to those little girls
in my town they live down the road from
me I didn't know what was going on
uh representative Lakers
seems to me that was a family issue
and
number one would background check done
on the father or stepfather rather have
turned up anything and number two are we
going to background check every single
parent because that yes they came out of
the school but that was in their home
that that was happening and if you want
to stop that a you're going to have to
background check every parent because it
happens in homes all over the place they
say one in four
girls has been sexually abused by a
family member
okay
so I don't see how doing background
checks is going to stop that and number
two these things do happen in public
schools too
they definitely do I mean I know lots of
examples including my granddaughter's
best friend
so the background checks I don't see
you're looking for
something a miracle to help something
that it's not going to help you it
sounds like you're I mean yes you want
to help them I want to help them I want
to protect all those kids and get abused
by their parents
or step parents or parents boyfriends or
girlfriends or whatever
uncles
but background checks doesn't seem to do
it none of those people fail background
checks I bet you that I mean I'm I would
be willing to bet that that
father-in-law did not fail or would not
fail a background check and because it's
happening in homes I don't know how
we're going to stop that by doing
background checks on
parents and a number of these things
that are in here that we want them on
are places where parents are present are
keeping an eye and and I think they're
actually less likely to have problems
than the public schools where we're not
keeping an eye
thank you again the bill can be adjusted
up and down to change things the main
idea here is we need to make sure that
people who are working with children are
safe to work with children so however
you want to hate this bill or be angry
at me because I filed it because you
think it's against efas that's not the
issue the issue is we need to make sure
we do something to protect children
while working with adults we need to
make sure that the Bad actors do not
get access through programs that don't
require that they be checked before they
work with children so I hope that you
will understand the point of view I hope
that someone will file a bill next term
that will make sure that anybody that
works in small groups with children
without another adult for more than so
many hours a week
has a background check before they are
paid by the State dollars and that thank
you very much for listening
remember someone representative cordelli
I swore I was not going to speak on this
bill but I am a co-sponsor of the bill
so uh hence my seat at the table I
am I have a question just I I am trying
to figure out why private schools who
are already doing a background check
would have trouble
or have a problem with a statute that
says that they have to conduct a
background check it doesn't seem to me
it seems to me like it would be an a a
wash on if they're already doing it and
it becomes part of the statute I'm not
sure why that would be a problem whether
it's a Catholic school or Dairy Field
school or whomever it happens to be in
terms of the private school aspect
um
second of all
um I yeah I
think that we're we're
getting off track when we talk about
somebody having to
some parent having to have a background
check to
homeschool their own child I mean I I
that that would not be something that
that would have been on my list of
highlights what would have been on my
list of highlights is the concept of the
micro school or the micro
program or whatever where somebody's
being dropped off at the library because
they're going to be one of four kids
that is studying with somebody that
nobody knows and nobody's mother's in
the room that's the scenario that I am
most concerned about so if if we were
able to find a way just to Target those
in public schools we call them
designated volunteers and they have to
have a background check because they're
designated to be with kids alone if
there was a way that we could just cover
that cohort
um
I would be very satisfied
thank you representative Tanner
um I totally agree with representative
Mullen and as I pointed out before there
is a statute about volunteers that that
tries to Define it and says that if they
are spending a significant amount of
time alone with with children I also
think that a few years
well I also think that education where
what we're overseeing and has
traditionally been one of the safety
nets for students safety nets for food
insecurity safety net for homeless and
safety net for abuse and that that covid
really wrecked a lot of that that was
you know that's the harmony Montgomery
one where you have a child who all of a
sudden is schooled and then under covet
just is missing and not not
taken into account or anything so I
think that um what we're looking at is
trying to provide some sort of safety
net that's connected with education
where if somebody is spending time alone
with a student either online micro
School uh
Public School volunteer coach I and I
would I would kind of think that little
league as an organization probably has
some standards on background checks for
for those people as well as Camp Stu I
mean again I'll I'll bring it back that
even camps in New Hampshire have to have
all their counselors background checked
in order uh to run the camp legitimate
you know to get this certification from
New Hampshire so I don't think this is
pie in the sky I think obviously I think
you're right representative electus
we're never going to totally rule out
abuse at home
um we can't uh the government's not
going into people's houses and you know
doing background checks that's not what
we're talking about what we're talking
about is people that are working with
students under the guise of Education
under the guise of Public Funding that
are spending time alone with students
either online or individ in a school of
some type that they should they should
fall under the background check rule
would represent bone can I ask a
question so uh in this in a case of uh
micro educational situation or whatever
who would be responsible if um I mean
you know obviously if if a teacher at
school or a volunteer at school does
something that they're not supposed to
it's the school district that's
ultimately responsible who would be
responsible if do parents sign a waiver
on child safety I mean how does how does
that work
um
first of all
um I I think most of the conversation
about micro schools
is pointed toward pranda learning pods
and there are two flavors
um one flavor is a district pod where
the district sets up the learning pod
with prenda and or in charge of
everything and hire the teacher
um or The Apprentice guide Etc the other
is a community pod
um where parents get together and work
with prenda and
um have their choice of prenda guides to
hire uh Brenda is under contract to the
State Department of Education
uh prenda does background checks on
employment background checks on all
their guides as part of their hiring
process
um and let me also mention that
um uh I'm very disturbed about any
indication that uh someone might be
homeschooling in order to keep their
kids at home
um to cover up or uh prolong abuse of
that child
um
as a member of the home education
advisory Council I am very concerned
about any indications
or opinions along those lines
ruptured bone I think you had in your
hand up thank you yeah just remember
this is an interim study no matter what
we say here
you can still put in the bill
now I think this bill goes too far and
some things on maybe somebody can come
up with language but interim study I
mean it's a nice way of killing a bill
and that's what this is we've anybody
can put in the bill next year no matter
what we say and we don't know who's
going to be on the education committee
next year maybe none of us here so it's
all going to be new information one way
or another so also I was also on a home
education advisory counseled some 10
years ago anyway and that time we asked
that question have there been to the doe
at the time have we had any cases for
home education due to abuse and I think
it was five years even before that they
had one case from Manchester out of all
the thousands of kids in a home school
so it's it's not an issue it's no big of
an issue than any place else so I don't
believe homeschool kids I don't know of
any cases I haven't heard of any cases
so I think this bill goes way too far of
what's needed thank you representative
cordelli so back to my question about I
was doing everything I could not to use
the word pranda because I didn't want to
Target anybody as uh the micro school
um if the State Department of Education
hires them
and prenda has already done a background
check then I don't understand why they
wouldn't feel that they were complying
with a statute that said that they had
to have a background check so I
I well I I would say I I don't know if
we want to put in
um statute any particular organization
that might
um have a contract oh no no no no that
was my point that's why I was saying
micro schools or whatever uh
right
um
yes representative and I just I just
want to I I know you emphasized that it
was Employee background checks this is
the other complexity that that
representative Mullen and I and Diana
Fenton and whoever worked on these
background checks is that there's
different levels of background checks
and that for people who spend time alone
with children
um in educational settings there's a
specific
background check
list of what has to pop up versus
somebody who takes a job at Grove Pony
Ford for example they do an employment
background check uh they're more
concerned about arson about you know
robbery assault that kind of things they
they really don't get down into some of
the weeds that the educational
background checks do so just so there's
two level there's more than two levels
but
um just want to point that out
reverse reporter so before I get
attacked again as a
um saying that I am against
homeschooling I am not against
homeschooling nor do I think
nor nor do I agree with the implication
that you uh said representative that I
thought
it happens
it does happen and we don't have anybody
now
who goes and visits the home schools all
of that regulation is gone so it can
happen and to hide our heads in the sand
saying it only happens a few times is
not to me enough I can but I agree that
the bill goes too far to say parents and
I didn't intend for parents to be the
ones that had all had background checks
but if someone comes in
and works with a group of children alone
without another adult there for certain
periods of time over the course of a
week we need to make sure that they are
safe for children so you can
do whatever you want with the bill I
don't really care at this point
but I am you know I mean this is
important stuff do what you want
any other
but okay
um I think representative Cornell is not
on there it's not me no no
on the committee that were appointed yep
and if there's a substitute they have to
be appointed by the chair and I have
appointed no substitute right right so
we had cordelli
and quarter of 10.
okay
it's four right there so Wireless
quarters candidates 3 by 57 on this one
okay
any yes I just have one more question if
you don't mind
um is there anything that prevents a
school district in a home school town
from calling the parent who might be
homeschooling and checking in and saying
hey how's it going is there is there any
is that allowed or
uh you know I don't think there's
anything uh in statute about uh
preventing it but um I I think that uh
um homeschoolers might uh get a little
upset to have the school district just
calling up and asking uh how you doing
uh is everything okay
I think that might be a a stretch
the superintendent school
that's responsibility to know how all
children in that District receive their
education yes are the
um
um I too think that homeschooling you
know has its purpose and has its has its
place what I question is when you said
the superintendent is responsible for
the education of all children within the
district I was at a recent school board
meeting and and somebody either I can't
remember if it was on the board or
somebody in the audience asked the
superintendent how many school how many
students in his district
were homeschooled and he said really I
have no idea because they just have to
check in at the very beginning of their
homeschooling and then I don't know if
they move I don't know where they are so
he had no
he couldn't even come up with a number
he had a rough number but he couldn't
come up with a number
I think under the
um legislation we passed last year
um and possibly before if
um now if you do move
um you're supposed and you would um
originally
um filed your intent with the local
superintendent you're supposed to let
that person know
um that you are yeah right yeah
how do you enforce that
how would you enforce it if if the the
family says we're homeschooling our
children and and at the end of the year
they're supposed to say okay you know
we're done or we're moving but they move
and they don't tell anybody and that's
against the law but how do you enforce
that because they've moved to Florida
and they don't register that they're
homeschooling or they don't register
them in a public school or any kind of
school so those children have just
disappeared
can't enforce them
right um
how many people
moved to Florida and neglect to tell the
Board of Elections that they're moving
and uh not deregister from voting here
in New Hampshire but it's a problem even
though with public school students
because as my previous Life as a
guidance counselor students wouldn't
show up at the beginning of the year and
would look for them and the neighbors
would say oh they've moved to Florida we
never got a request for records nobody
ever heard from them again so they
disappeared so we never found out what
was happening with those kids
across in there
yes but these are students that are
registered in schools that after that
disappear they're already registered and
then they're gone
yeah I don't know if that relates
directly to this legislation but uh
um so
um we've had
quite a bit of discussion on uh 1664
um representative Bohm I like to make a
motion that we
not recommend this bill for moving
forward
do you have a second
laughs
okay
um just any yeah just further discussion
representative I mean like I said before
interim study actually really means
nothing you can put the build in again
you can put a bill in differently and
I'm and and some other recommendation I
mean thing on this bill which makes it
makes it clearer or less I might even
like but this bill goes way too far and
that's why but
it's way it's way overboard thank you
option
representative Porter yeah you know the
only and I agree with you
with your polite death but when we say
that the bill itself we didn't like but
we do recommend
future legislation because the concept
itself is important
so that's the difference to me between
just saying I don't think we should have
a bill on this or I do think eventually
we should have a bill on this that's how
my I interpret it
and this still takes another vote by the
whole committee and that can be brought
up there
is that if you're looking for why I'm
going to do not support this bill moving
forward I just tried to write some
things down here learning pods are
allowed under New Hampshire law
and consistent with existing home
education law
to have family members friends or
someone else supervised children I'm
concerned by doing what we're doing here
we're really going to be impacting
homeschooling education in the state
where we have many students being
homeschooled in in a way that there's
consequences which haven't been thought
of here in this committee so I I cannot
support it moving forward as as is right
now
thank you
um shall we representative Lakers
comment
actually a question do we require
background checks for babysitters
because they're also spending time and
they could be the high school kid and I
I just I I think representative Porter
would say that they're not accepting
public funds
okay
that I know of
okay shall we take a a vote
um all those who agree with the motion
of not moving forward with this
legislation
um raise your hand
and those opposed to the motion
four to two I see
great well thank you very very much and
I think the full committee meets on the
24th is it for our final determination
on all the enorm study bills
see you soon
uh tomorrow I have excuse me I didn't
mean to
you